você olha a sua língua quando acorda
aqui é o Dr Alan Dutra médico há mais de
25 anos e hoje eu vou falar sobre a
nossa língua e como ela guarda muito
segredo sobre a nossa saúde depois de
assistir esse vídeo Pegue um espelho e
dê uma olhada na sua língua isso porque
muitas doenças apresentam sintomas que
podem ser identificados na língua em
alguns casos esses sinais não ficam
evidentes Até que a doença esteja mais
avançada ou em estágio grave mas o nosso
corpo geralmente é dar pistas muito
antes disso acontecer e a língua pode
revelar sinais surpreendentes pessoal
uma língua saudável é brilhante fina
Rosada e úmida quando surgem problemas
digestórios a superfície da língua pode
acumular resíduos como bactérias fungos
toxinas e restos alimentares formando a
chamada saburra lingual essa camada pode
variar de cor mas geralmente é
esbranquiçada e se concentra na
superfície especialmente no centro da
língua e a presença dessa burra lingual
pode sinalizar má digestão ou uma
digestão incompleta levando a um excesso
de toxinas
acumuladas especialmente com a ingestão
de álcool excesso de carboidratos
açúcares Laticínios produtos
industrializados e seus conservantes se
você usa um raspador de língua e percebe
que ela volta ao seu aspecto normal isso
indica que que a coloração esbranquiçada
era um acúmulo de resíduos que a higiene
oral conseguiu remover porém se a
saburra persiste mesmo após uma limpeza
adequada ou se você nota outras mudanças
na cor formato ou textura da língua isso
pode ser um sinal de problemas de saúde
Vamos explorar agora o que esses outros
tipos de alterações podem indicar e como
interpretá-los pessoal a língua é um
órgão muscular que nos ajuda a falar
saborear e engolir Além disso desempenha
diversas funções sendo na boca que a
digestão dos alimentos começa é onde
iniciamos a absorção dos nutrientes que
consumimos quando você vai ao médico ele
geralmente escuta o coração examina os
pulmões mas os praticantes de medicinas
como a tradicional chinesa acreditam que
a aparência da língua pode conter pistas
valiosas sobre nossa saúde por isso
pedem para mostrar a língua médicos que
seguem abordagens diferenciadas como a
medicina funcional e do estilo de vida
geralmente também solicitam pro paciente
mostrar a língua por qu eles analisam a
cor formato revestimento e umidade da
língua buscando pistas de possíveis
problemas uma das coisas que esses
médicos podem identificar ao observar a
língua é a deficiência de nutrientes a
língua apresenta pequenas elevações
chamadas papilas gustativas
que são saliências naturais
inofensivas essas pequenas saliências
ajudam a reconhecer o sabor dos
alimentos contribuindo ainda para evitar
incômodos intoxicações na boca no
entanto se a sua língua estiver vermelha
como um morango Lisa sem papilas
visíveis isso pode indicar deficiência
de três nutrientes muito importantes
ferro ácido fólico que é a vitamina B9 e
principalmente a alamina que é a
vitamina b122 A condição conhecida como
glossite é uma inflamação na língua que
pode fazer ela parecer Lisa devido ao
inchaço a vitamina B12 e o ferro são
essenciais para o desenvolvimento das
papilas sem esses nutrientes as papilas
desaparecem deixando a língua Lisa e
inflamada a falta da vitamina B12 pode
ainda causar alterações sensoriais na
língua pois ela é importante para
funcionamento neurológico das papilas
gustativas isso pode resultar em
Sensações como formigamento queimação
dormência insensibilidade mesmo sem
lesões aparentes além disso a
deficiência de vitamina B12 pode causar
alterações no paladar e sensação de boca
seca já a deficiência de ferro também
pode causar inchaço e até mesmo feridas
dolorosas na língua uma língua
avermelhada Lisa dolorida inflamada
também pode ser causada pela pelagra uma
condição nutricional resultante da
deficiência de niacina a vitamina B3 b
de bola 3 essa doença pode provocar
alterações na pele diarreia e alterações
neurológicas como dor de cabeça confusão
mental e perda de memória além disso a
deficiência de vitamina A também pode
levar a alterações físicas na língua
resultando em uma forma diferente de
inflamação chamada língua
recortada nessa condição a língua
apresenta dor sensibilidade inchaço e
mudanças na cor mas a característica
principal é a borda recortada que cria
desenhos irregulares na lateral também
precisamos ficar atentos a outras
deficiências nutricionais que afetam a
língua como as de falta de vitamina C e
Zinco a deficiência de vitamina C em
particular pode resultar numa condição
chamada escorbuto subclínico o escorbuto
clássico embora considerado erradicado é
causado pela deficiência grave dessa
vitamina hoje o escorbuto subclínico é
caracterizado por uma falta
significativa de vitamina C que apesar
de não ser tão dramática quanto no
passado ainda pode causar sérios
problemas essa deficiência pode ser
identificada pela língua uma combinação
da língua mais avermelhada e brilhante
com manchas vermelhas nas laterais que
são microhemorragias pode ser um sinal
de alerta outro indício importante é o
sangramento nas gengivas que pode ser um
sintoma de deficiência de vitamina
C bom você sabia que o tamanho da língua
também pode indicar problemas de saúde
como saber se sua língua é grande demais
para sua boca depois de assistir esse
vídeo vá o espelho e ao colocar a língua
para fora Observe se a marcas de dentes
nas laterais isso indica a macroglossia
um aumento da língua se a língua aumenta
de tamanho de forma repentina isso pode
ser uma reação alérgica ou uma infecção
requerendo ajuda médica imediata mas se
o inchaço ocorre lentamente ao longo dos
meses isso pode ser um sinal de
hipotiroidismo quando o corpo não produz
hormônios tiroidianos de forma
suficiente nesse caso as marcas laterais
dos dentes são um sinal bastante comum
dessa doença que afeta a tireoide
pessoal outra condição que pode causar o
crescimento da língua é a acromegalia
quando o corpo produz hormônio de
crescimento em excesso o chamado HG ou
GH É raro Mas pode fazer com que a
língua cresça de forma desproporcional a
amiloidose que é um grupo de doenças
raras ocorre quando as proteínas
amiloides se depositam em diversos
órgãos pelo corpo essa condição também
pode resultar no aumento da língua pois
envolve o acúmulo de proteínas amiloides
até na língua fazendo ela crescer embora
condições raras como a acromegalia e
amiloidose possam causar aumento da
língua o hipotiroidismo é a causa mais
comum levando ao inchaço e aquelas
marcas laterais dos dentes e quanto às
fissuras ou rachaduras na língua muitas
vezes quando você olha no espelho pode
perceber algumas fendas às vezes mais
profundas na sua língua na maioria dos
casos são inofensivas Mas podem causar
sintomas como ardência e até mau hálito
Já que as fissuras podem acumular
bactérias e toxinas quem tem essas
fissuras precisa manter uma higiene
bucal rigorosa para evitar problemas
agora pessoal se você notar essas
rachaduras acompanhadas de outros
sintomas pode ser um sinal de uma
síndrome autoimune chamada síndrome de
jren ou Doença de jren ela é uma doença
reumática crônica que causa inflamação
em certas glândulas do corpo
principalmente nas glândulas da boca e
dos olhos isso pode resultar em sintomas
como boca e olhos secos dificuldade para
engolir e um risco maior de infecções
nesses locais levando a inflamação e
inchaço da língua portanto se você
perceber inchaço fissuras rachaduras na
língua e uma sensação de boca mais seca
do que habitual pode ser o indicativo
dessa doença autoimune vale a pena
conversar com o seu médico para uma
avaliação mais detalhada encontrar a
melhor forma de cuidar da sua saúde Mais
um ponto importante sobre as fissuras na
língua elas podem estar conectadas a
sentimentos como ansiedade e medo além
de alterações do sistema nervoso central
e insônia portanto se você tem notado
essas fissuras e está lidando com
estresse ou dificuldades para dormir
vale a pena prestar atenção na saúde
emocional Pois o bem-estar da mente pode
estar refletido na língua vamos falar um
pouco mais sobre a cor da língua uma
língua com sabor esbranquiçada é muitas
vezes resultado crescimento excessivo de
fungos na boca especialistas apontam que
a diabetes ou a resistência à insulina
podem estar por trás dessa coloração
como mencionei antes se você raspar a
língua e os esbranquiçados aparecem pode
ser apenas um acúmulo de saburra lingual
no entanto se a coloração permanece
mesmo após raspar pode ser sinal de
candidíase oral a candidíase oral é uma
infecção fúndica que pode ser dolorosa
causando manchas brancas ou avermelhadas
na língua e até dificultando engolir ou
comer outra possível causa de língua
branca é a leucoplasia que cria manchas
ou placas brancas geralmente associadas
ao uso de tabaco além disso liqu em
plano um tipo de erupção cutânea também
pode deixar a língua com manchas
esbranquiçadas outras condições que
podem alterar a cor da língua incluem
gastrite efeitos colaterais antibióticos
e problemas gastrointestinais já uma
língua com sabur assentada pode indicar
problemas nos pulmões no coração e nos
intestinos há também uma condição
chamada língua geográfica dando à língua
uma aparência de mapa com camadas
esbranquiçadas ou assentadas
o eczema é outra condição que pode mudar
a cor da língua um estudo de 2019
mostrou que 43% dos participantes com
equizema tinham uma língua assentada
portanto Fique atento a essa cor pessoal
quando a língua apresenta um Tom Marrom
preto isso pode sinalizar uma condição
chamada língua preta ou língua pilosa
nessa condição as papilas ficam mais
longas formando pequenas protuberâncias
que podem até dar a impressão de ser
pelos o crescimento das papilas pode
reter bactérias restos alimentares e
corantes levando ao escurecimento essa
condição está associada Principalmente
ao hábito de fumar ao excesso de consumo
de café e a má higiene bucal Além disso
pode surgir como efeito colateral de
medicamentos como antibióticos ou
antihistamínicos se a sua língua
apresentar essa coloração vale a pena
revisar os seus hábitos e procurar um
dentista para uma orientação agora
atenção se a sua língua ficar com tom
arrochado azulado Porque isso pode
indicar mass circulação sanguínea ou
problemas cardíacos por exemplo uma
língua azulada pode ser resultado da
Baixa oxigenação do sangue decorrente de
problemas respiratórios como doença
pulmonar obstrutiva crônica o chamado
DPOC doenças vasculares e até doenças
renais o nível baixo de oxigênio no
sangue é muito sério então se você
perceber essa alteração língua azulada
busque ajuda médica imediatamente a
língua também pode ficar roxa como sinal
de uma doença Rara e grave chamada
doença de cavac que causa inflamação dos
vasos sanguíneos e quando você percebe
que a sua língua está amarelada isso
pode em primeiro lugar estar relacionado
ao que você comeu se após higienizar a
boca a coloração não persistir pode ser
que tenha sido apenas algo passageiro
porém se a coloração permanecer mesmo
após a limpeza e por dias é importante
prestar atenção uma língua levemente
amarelada pode ser sinal de desidratação
indicando que você precisa ingerir mais
água diariamente Agora se a língua
continua amarela por mais tempo pode
apontar uma infecção bacteriana ou em
alguns casos um problema no fígado a
icterícia devido a uma doença hepática
grave pode deixar a pele e a parte
branca dos olhos amareladas além de
causar o mesmo efeito na língua pessoal
Olha que interessante um estudo de 2019
indicou que a língua amarela ou
amarelada pode ser um sinal de diabetes
ou pré-diabetes se você tem sintomas de
diabetes não diagnosticado e a sua
língua está persistentemente amarelada
vale a pena investigar compartil os
vídeos bem a de alguém pode também no
canal AL dovv
Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração
Você é fera